Sonic the Hedgehog streets of rage
Aladdin there are plenty of classic
games that call the sega mega drive home
if you want to relive the feeling of
booting up Sega's first console on your
CRT TV this news is for you the Sega
Mega Drive classics hub is coming to
steam on Thursday April twenty-eighth as
a free update prepare to go neon the hub
itself is modeled after a 90 sega kids
bedroom you can boot up your retro CRT
TV choose a game off your virtual shelf
and load it up note that this is simply
an emulator for running your games
you'll still need to buy one of the many
Genesis or Mega Drive games available on
Steam but once you do you'll have access
to local co-op enhancement filters save
states and full controller support
symbol would be proud if you're a fan of
90 Sega games then the Mega Drive
classics hub is for you and if you own
any of the supported games already
you'll have access to the hub by default
to stay up to date on all things Sega
keep it locked to gamespot I'm Tony you
can follow me on twitter at chain-gun
Pope and I've got some Aladdin to play